in addition to being a scientist I have
two other passions when is photography
and actually I had a exhibit of my
photographs in Paris and they have
nothing to do at all with a science some
of them were taken in Norway I don't in
the exhibit that's not the way in the
1950s and 60s travel a lot and took
kodachrome pictures and after why for a
while Emily took pictures of my family
and the thinking of maybe making up and
exhibit from from those photographs now
that I'm sort of better known as a
photographer and the other thing is that
you know when we do these calculations
we don't really do any chemistry and so
the chemistry that I do do is actually
cooking and I've for many years I used
to work in famous restaurants and France
and such for two or three weeks every
summer and work in the kitchen and
replaced the people who were taking
their day off and so that was the real
chemistry that I like to do and still at
home now I do the cooking and my wife
that's the dishwashing and such and
that's so I think it's nice if being a
scientist when you work you really work
full time I think that's one of the
things you have to realize they said you
have to work really very hard you can be
smart but that's not enough but for me
the very important part is okay I work
very hard when I'm doing science but
then I do other things and we do them as
well and I think that's a good way of
living it's also better for obviously
for your family if you can sort of
divide your time a little bit then we
have a chalet in the outside wall
why used to we love to go walking and
such and I think that's for me at least
somebody has written that actually it's
in the preface of the photo book that
every scientist has a secret garden and
that's my secret diary